[Musica]
ci sono dei concetti che vengono
utilizzati soprattutto un po per
pigrizia un po per moda
uno di questi concetti e quello di
resilienza la resilienza e alla
proprietà di un metallo di ritornare
allo stato iniziale dopo aver subito uno
shock
ecco che quindi dopo la crisi economica
soprattutto italiana tutti noi avevamo
un sacco bisogno di essere resilienti e
si andava ai convegni degli imprenditori
delle associazioni e c'era appunto
questa volontà di essere residenti era
pensiero desideranti si voleva tornare
allo stato precedente a quello della
crisi economica il problema però è che
gli individui ei gruppi di individui le
persone non sono mai resiliente perché
dopo uno shock dopo una crisi o
involvono oppure evolvono non sono mai
resilienti per definizione un concetto
simile è quello di disintermediazione in
realtà il concetto di determinazione
coglie gli aspetti della realtà molto
importanti non prenoto più il viaggio in
agenzia di viaggio ma lo facciamo
direttamente online non vado più allo
sportello della banca ma uso l'home
banking
non devo più andare ad un commento di un
politico ma posso sentirlo punto in
diretta ad esempio su facebook
prendiamo approfondiamo brevemente il
caso dell'home banking fino 10 20 anni
fa
andavamo in in banca c'erano sacco di
sportellisti il dome contanti
compilavano i moduli ora diciamo così la
figura di uno sportellista per una quota
parte è stata disintermediata andiamo
sulla home banking facciamo tutto lì
però l'home banking è un filtro non è
nulla è qualcosa medium qualcosa che sta
in mezzo fra noi e quello che vogliamo
fare quello di cui ci vogliamo informare
e non è neutra lo sa benissimo che
costruisce i siti internet
l'architettura del sito internet fatto
in maniera tale da incentivare alcune
decisioni alcuni comportamenti piuttosto
che altri
ecco quindi sì c'è una
disintermediazione
ma c'è anche una neo intermediazione in
terminazione molto diversa da quella
tradizionale ma non è che non esiste
cioè è diversa
passiamo dall'esempio economico quello
politico occupied wall street ve lo
ricorderete un movimento di qualche anno
fa di giovani che protestava contro
quelle che loro ritenevano essere gli
abusi e gli eccessi del capitalismo
finanziario erano giovani molto spesso a
new york in tante città in contesti
urbani volevano far passare a loro
messaggio politico twittavano twittavano
twittavano però non riuscivano a finire
sui trend i trend con la sezione del
sito twitter in cui twitter dice beh
questi questi tweet questi hashtag sono
interessanti vanno stanno bucando se
finisci su trend il tuo messaggio ancora
più forza e pure loro twittavano tutta
la notavano e non riuscivano a passare
tanto è vero che a un certo punto siete
fusano voce magari ci si censurano ma
diamo per scontato che questo non sia
accaduto in realtà non lo possiamo
verificare perché gli algoritmi delle
aziende private sono privati però non
punto non è questo il punto è che c'è
una scelta editoriale si dice
probabilmente in quel periodo twitter
preferiva degli hashtag molto diffusi
sul territorio molto diffusi socialmente
queste erano tutti ragazzi erano tutti
appartenenti alla classe creativa
cosiddetta creativa
erano tutti in contesti urbani insomma
non sono riusciti a passare come
avrebbero voluto
è la neo intermediazione sono nuovi
centri di potere che hanno un ruolo nel
plasmare la sfera pubblica
quali sono gli effetti ma uno degli
effetti quello che chiama il paradosso
del pluralismo
ora con internet le voci disponibili
sono aumentate in maniera esponenziale
su questo non c'è alcun dubbio
ricorda un po la star a la stampa a
caratteri mobili di gutenberg
innovazione che portò un sacco di libro
usato di pamphlet giornali articoli che
fu molto importante perché costruì la
sfera pubblica e il dibattito pubblico
su cui poi si basano lei le democrazie
moderne e contemporanee
bene questa sfera pubblica viene
rinforzata da internet internet dal
punto di vista quantitativo da sempre
maggiori informazioni il pluralismo però
non è un concetto facile e giovanni
sartori un grande politologo italiano
dice che il pluralismo non è soltanto
quantitativo numero di fonti di
informazione ma anche qualitativo e lo
spiega con un esempio la differenza fra
le fazioni medievali partiti moderni le
fazioni medievale erano tantissime
guelfi bianchi quel fine riti bellini il
problema è che quando c'era la
competizione elettorale se le davano di
santa ragione molto spesso chi perdeva
finiva in esilio è successa una cosa
simile anche a dante alighieri il poeta
anche partiti moderni sono tanti li
conosciamo ma la differenza fondamentale
è che se perde le elezioni non viene
cacciato ha il diritto di tribuna ha il
diritto di parola puoi continuare a
confrontarti e quindi questo il
pluralismo autentico non è tante fonti
di informazione tanti si è anche questo
non è questo il cuore il cuore che ci
sono tante voci a tante voci che non
sono delle monadi autoreferenziali ma
che discutono si confrontano fra di loro
fra diversi almeno almeno in parte c'è
quindi un pure un pluralismo paradossale
probabilmente su internet perché su
inter nella quantità aumenta molto ma la
qualità della qualità non parlano tanti
ricercatori studiosi americani anche
italiani hanno parlato dell'eco chambers
camere dell'eco quando sono su internet
sui soci sulle piattaforme soprattutto
la mia voce viene messa e mi ritorna
indietro ancora più forte come se fosse
appunto in una stanza vuota
e questo perché accade gli esseri umani
tendono al omofilia cosa significa che
frequentiamo persone o idee che sono
simili a noi e questo è naturale ma su
internet c'è qualcosa di più perché le
piattaforme innanzitutto anno interessa
fare in modo che gli utenti delle
piattaforme stiano in questo contesto
perché significa più pubblicità perché
che significa più dati da poter vendere
magari aggregati ad altre imprese quindi
l'obiettivo è la gente deve restare lì
il più possibile ma quindi cosa bisogna
dargli bisogna dargli quello che gli
piace se ti piacciono cani e ducali non
filo gatti
ecco che quindi viviamo profilati
veniamo studiati anche con i big data e
la nostra offerta che ci viene data
un'offerta personalizzata
una ricerca su google che faccio io su
una parola è diversa da quella che
farebbe un altra persona
questo un certo punto di vista molto
bello molto comodo ma per quanto
riguarda la sfera pubblica può creare
dei problemi quelle del problema riduce
l'incontro casuale
badate bene nella nella realtà fra
virgolette le cose sono ben diverse
perché se io sono un dipendente pubblico
e vado al lavoro la mattina
trovo colleghi che stati selezionati con
un bando per le loro capacità
amministrative e quindi io sono possa
essere centrosinistra possa incontrare
un collega del centrodestra un collega
di cinque stelle magari non ci vado a
bere la birra magari non gli aggiungo su
facebook
però intanto passa a 8 ore con loro il
pluralismo è anche in senso qualitativo
su internet la cosa è diversa
ecco che quindi neo intermediazione
paradosso pluralismo sono dei concetti
che ci suggeriscono che sono dei poteri
con cui dobbiamo fare i conti e che
hanno delle conseguenze sul nostro
essere cittadini
quindi cosa bisogna fare secondo me
innanzitutto prima cosa non dimenticare
le lezioni della filosofia politica del
passato
la filosofia politica del passato una
cosa molto semplice che il potere cambia
ma rimane che ha a spinte orizzontali
vengono contrapposti spinte
centralizzate verticistiche e non fare
finta che questo non ci siano nè che
significa automaticamente vivere in un
mondo più libero più bello più felice
significa semplicemente non rendersi non
avere le chiavi di lettura per leggere i
nuovi flussi di potere
flussi di potere sono rilevanti sono
privati le piattaforme le grandi aziende
ma anche pubblici perché anche lo stato
ha i governi hanno dei degli strumenti
di manipolazione e anche di gestione
delle masse degli individui sempre più
forti sempre più sofisticati di nuovo
però il passato può darci una mano può
darci una chiave di lettura un modo in
cui approcciare il problema è quello che
vi propongo oggi è il concetto di habeas
corpus parto da questo la vas corpo è
stato lacca il cardine della nostra
libertà ai nostri diritti come cittadini
il sovrano inglese secoli fa tentare
dell'inter assoluto di imporre un potere
assoluto assolutista un potere di vita e
di morte sui suoi sudditi poter
arbitrario slegato dalle leggi ma a
nobili e borghesi questa cosa non andava
bene e imposero al sovrano di concedere
all'habeas corpus ab il tuo corpo
la bers corpo significa che ognuno di
noi è libero può muoversi e è autonomo
a meno che appunto si può essere
bloccato solo in questioni giustificate
e non arbitraria però secoli fa quando è
nato là bas corpus il potere ad
ascoltato fisico l'erario di una
monarchia in gran parte andava in
esercito gli strumenti di repressione
ora al potere soprattutto con la
tecnologia digitale e non è soltanto
fisico e mentale è simbolico linguistico
e culturale
ecco che quindi bisogna passare da una
brass corpus che resta importante
fondamentale a una brass mentem ab la
tua mente
bisogna cercare di capire quali sono i
meccanismi istituzionali pesi e
contrappesi diritti che permettono ai
cittadini di essere il più possibile i
liberi autonomi per loro valutazioni e
nelle loro decisioni
c'è tanto da fare fino a dieci anni fa
il diritto fondamentale quando si
parlava di internet
era il diritto alla connessione alla
connettività il digital divide il
divario digitale c'è chi escluso cech è
incluso in internet quindi portiamo
interne a tutti questa cosa è una cosa
molto importante valevole ancora oggi ma
è un po superata perché ormai insomma
con lo smartphone ognuno di noi con
pochi soldi a una buona connessione
la sfida ora di diritti è diversa e
nuova riguarda il diritto all'oblio
riguarda il rito alla privacy riguarda
il diritto a reed entità digitale e alla
portabilità dell'identità digitale
riguarda diritti come quello alla
crittografia che ricollega gli hacker
una cosa un po scura però alla fine gli
hacker sono coloro che conoscono un
sistema operativo sono consapevoli e poi
sanno dove mettere le mani se necessario
mettere le mani la crittografia
interessante perché di default ora la
crittografia nelle nostre comunicazioni
su internet non c'è molti sistemi ma
questo crea nuove disuguaglianze non è
più la disuguaglianza digitali veit è la
nuova disuguaglianza basata sul fatto
che chi ha potere chi è una grande
azienda e consulente che gli permettono
di avere delle connessioni delle
comunicazioni sicure e chi è casalinga
che operaio che studente magari clicca
la spunta sul regola sul regolamento del
social momento la prima volta poi si
dimentica e questo è un problema è un
problema e si potrebbe dire che però non
abbiamo in fondo non abbiamo nulla da
nascondere
il che potrebbe essere vero ora sarebbe
curioso a fare un esperimento chiamare
la signora in prima fila farla venire
qui e mostrarci le sue ultime ricerche
su google
ecco forse avrebbe qualcosa da ridire ma
porto il concetto all'estremo perché
perché a ferrara un progetto bisogna
portarlo all'estremo gli ebrei nei
secoli precedenti frequentavano l'europa
si spostavano di città in città che
lasciavano dati informazioni con si
spostavano quello che so una donazione
sinagoga tutto tutto bene
finché non arrivò il diavolo veramente
il diavolo con i baffetti a passo
dell'oca e vi lascio immaginare cosa
cercavano gli ufficiali nazisti quando
conquistavano nuova città ecco questa
cosa qui ha portato all'estremo
ovviamente però ci suggerisce un punto
fondamentale il più importante che
quando progettiamo le istituzioni
diritti i pesi e contrappesi non li
dobbiamo progettare pensando di un
potere buono sempre buono sempre gentile
sempre generoso perchè se fosse sempre
così non ci sarebbe bisogno di norme
dobbiamo pensare le istituzioni i paesi
contrappesi diritti a quando il potere
rischia di essere cattivo rischia di
approfittare della sua posizione io non
dico con questo discorso che dobbiamo
essere favorevoli alla privacy alla
crittografia non sto dicendo questo dico
che dobbiamo pensarci che la cosa molto
diversa e molto importante
io credo che la forma più alta di
libertà e di consapevolezza e di
autonomia sia avere la consapevolezza
della fragilità della propria libertà e
della propria autonomia
non è un paradosso è proprio così e
quindi credo che dobbiamo ispirarci un
po il pensiero hacker essere consapevole
sapere dove mettere le mani e metterle
se necessario
dobbiamo cominciare quindi questo
percorso che è tutto da costruire
facciamo quindi il mondo che le grandi
potenzialità delle tecnologie digitali
non siano soltanto un involuzione ma
siano soprattutto un evoluzione e che
siano per tutti noi un occasione di
progresso grazie
[Applauso]